let's talk about mr elon musk oh my god
from cnbc elon musk says he will pay
over 11 billion dollars in taxes this
year did you see the babylon bee
interview today with him i did i saw a
little bit of it where the guys sitting
around interviewing him were so cringe
actually they're like uh we don't even
know why we're talking to you
i was like bro he's there he agreed you
just need to ask questions with
confidence but i didn't i didn't see you
guys are cool dudes
yeah but uh
come
um i tweeted at elon once he tweeted at
me we're friends now you're right i'm
kidding and together you guys are gonna
pay 12 billion in taxes this year that's
right uh so i'm disappointed in this i
think elon should not have done this he
did it to make a point and to try and
defang you know people like elizabeth
warren which okay i suppose is still a
good thing here's here's what i think
happened they've been saying people who
are wealthy should pay taxes on their
wealth the wealth tax so elon musk was
like okay should i liquidate my stock
and then pay taxes on it and people were
like do it he said okay i will so he
ends up giving the government 11 billion
dollars in taxes which empowers really
awful people to make a point
i suppose i suppose in that in that
that's a very expensive point i think
it's so expensive that you might want to
think that there's a different motive
there i i got it maybe he's been waiting
to liquidate those assets and this gave
him a good reason to do it etc you never
know you never know when he's making
tweets about crypto i don't think he
cares about the money you know there's a
certain amount of money where you don't
care but hit but to him money means mars
money means space money means advancing
the universe just like you tell me tim
you know you tell me you're not all
about the money what you're all about is
building new things creating new
opportunities starting these non-profits
having a serious impact on the world
you're a philanthropist already he's a
philanthropist and somebody who's
working towards the betterment of
society i believe sure sure so what i
was going to say in in the babylon b
interview he talks about
how he came to be worth so much money
the richest person in the world and he
said he doesn't have the money he
started a company
he owns i think what he's doing 20 of
the stock or something
and he's like i own 20 of the stock in a
company the investors decided the
company was worth one trillion dollars
so my stock is worth 200 billion dollars
i didn't do anything i don't have any
money they've just decided that and now
you know we get elizabeth warren being
like he's not paying any taxes because
she is a despicable person because you
know she knows she sold out bernie
sanders and they still they still you
know she understands the difference
between paper investment gains and
actual earned income you know she knows
the difference between these things did
the did the bill pass that had the
clause in it that said that we were
going to be taxed on unrealized capital
gains i don't think so i haven't heard
anymore because the bill that says that
you're going to be taxed on your mileage
driven that did pass yeah that did pass
there's provision in there to create a
pilot program to test out the best way
to tax people on their mileage driven
and the number that they were tossing
around was insane it was something like
eight cents a mile
that's like 2 000 bucks a year for the
average person elon basically is coming
out now saying i've paid more taxes in
the than any more taxes than any other
person in history and elizabeth warren
doesn't pay taxes
but she'll still keep lying because
these people are evil and elon musk did
this to make a point but it doesn't
matter dude there's a very interesting
analysis to be made of who where
is it for the betterment of society that
the government now has that 11 billion
or if elon musk had that 11 billion so
the the young turks had on ari the
rugged man to capture after yeah no
yeah and jenk was like looking at the
camera constantly like just trying to
bait me into a drama thing oh my god i
don't i don't think like he knows at all
who i am or whatever but so what i
decided to do is i had so many people
saying like
you don't need to prove anything tim you
don't need to respond to them and i'm
like no no hold on so you know the
rugged man comes on the show and he says
my experience has never happened i'm
lying and i'm like i just find it really
funny that like they admit and
acknowledge i am mixed race they admit
and acknowledge he is a white man
and that they agree with him when he
laughs at someone who says i'm mixed
race and i experience racism i want that
net narrative to persist i'm glad the
young turks made that video god those
guys are so trashy so i did i did a
video with my sister um and i put it up
at 1pm on
youtube.comcastnews 40 minutes long
where she we basically talk about you
know our childhood growing up and you
know why i wanted to address the young
turks and i didn't do it to prove any
point
necessarily like to them i didn't i
don't need the young turks to believe me
i
need you
to believe me
what i mean by this is
when the young turks come out and they
say tim poole lied and made all the
stuff up there will be people watching
saying yeah i wonder if he really did
lie make this stuff up and i'll say okay
i will have my sister on and we will
talk about everything we've been through
as embarrassing as it is for my family
and whatever people end up thinking
about us because i'm telling you the
truth and i want people to then look at
the young turks and see how they're
despicable racists and i want them to
look at me and my family and say these
people are talking about the true
struggles they've been through
the reason i bring that up is because
when people started commenting and
saying like you don't need to prove
anything to them
they are 100 correct i didn't do it to
prove anything to the young turks i did
it so regular people can see it i kind
of feel like elon might be doing some of
that
to sort of like let people know he's not
that guy
you know to use the meme he's he's not
the dude who's going to exploit
everybody and take all this money and
that he's more interested in going to
space and just so happens he has this
money i do kind of feel like part of it
though was to prove a point to to to the
democrats and he gave the government
money which he didn't need to do he did
not need to sell
billions of dollars in stock and then
pay the government all this money he
could have just kept it in stock and
said i have no reason to take the money
out i mean if he's paying 11 billion
dollars in taxes how much did he
liquidate and how much did he end up in
his pocket you gotta sell a lot of stock
to pay 11 billion in taxes 11 billion 20
right 20 capital gains or is a little
bit higher yeah i think it's 28 because
it might be higher than that it might be
way higher than that because of uh biden
it might actually be like 40 or
something somebody said
he netted he netted a good bit
yo people need to understand what a
billion dollars is
it's a thousand millions it's crazy i
you would not be able to spend it i'm
not exaggerating you would not be able
to spend it
people don't get this man there was this
thread well it depends on what you're
doing right because that new tesla
factory apparently is like some like 10
000
football feelings in size i mean i'm
exaggerating but i think it's something
as insane as that right i don't i don't
think you'd be able to spend it
i don't as a consumer as an individual
consumer yeah um as an individual
so if you if if you as a business
uh are are seeking to build a factory
that's you know a thousand football
fields or whatever yeah there's gonna be
way the logistics and that is gonna be
way beyond one person making a purchase
right this is going to be a massive
undertaking of different companies and
different ceos an individual would not
be able to spend that money elon musk
liquidating this money he's probably
shrugging saying i don't know right
because bro a super yacht what do those
go for like 30 million or something
30 million so what you got 970 million
left like i guess you can buy a
10 of them
but then you got to maintain them like
it's just
there's a certain amount of wealth where
you're sitting there confused as to what
you're even doing well you have to hire
people to figure out how to spend it
yeah i guess you hire people to figure
out how to manage it you hire people to
figure out how to spend it and then you
hire people to figure out how to defend
it
and then where to invest it this is
where the idea of a family office comes
in these people literally have to hire
for what to manage their money
for philanthropy eventually right i
suppose you know i feel like when you're
at the point where elon's at
i wonder why doesn't elon take a billion
dollars and say who wants to start a
media organization to go after the fake
news the liars
well i i mean isn't he i know peter
thiel at least has used some of his
money to his foundation which is for
education which is to to produce new
entrepreneurs so you know they're
they're giving pieces back i think maybe
they have different priorities you know
they have different priorities in terms
of what their philanthropy can do and
how it can affect the world for sure
these are smart guys making calculated
decisions there's no question about that
if i had a billion dollars
i would know exactly how to begin
allocating things towards solving a lot
of these problems
and so i suppose it's as simple as
elon musk wants to go to mars he has he
has a different perspective on what the
problems are and that's something his
company has to do
but my point is to be someone like elon
and know they're lying know the media
lies all the time yeah and to have the
ability to effectively snap your fingers
and challenge that that machine but he
can already do that with twitter and
social media no no no no no no he can't
look how much did bezos buy the
washington post for a couple hundred
million yeah peanuts basically peanuts
well i mean relative to his net worth
yeah elon musk could be like i could
fund that three times over and set up
three washington post operations that'll
operate indefinitely the guardian
operates off an endowment they just
generate interest off of some all the
money they have that helps fund
everything elon musk could literally be
like
okay
here's a billion dollars towards the
babylon b guys hey
you know people who are challenging the
machine you guys make jokes about it all
day
figure it out maybe he doesn't see it as
a problem like you do
maybe it's just not on his radar maybe
and maybe maybe he's being more
efficient with his capital allocation
who knows maybe you just can't be
everything to everybody why am i over
here carrying water pretty much
like i don't i think he's cool dude i
like him i don't think he's perfect i
think he does a lot of dumb stuff but um
i think i think he's a good dude and i
think he's he's genuine he wants to try
and he wants to be honest that's why
he's giving away all that's why he
liquidated these assets and he's paying
the billions in taxes you know what i
liked about fact that he did the uh the
babylon b interview he's like oh well i
read all your stuff
right it's not like he needs to go on
the show to sell anything or to pimp
anything or whatever you know but he
goes on the show because he's like they
they he he quoted back to them their own
headlines
i know and and they're like the one guy
was like wow you you know our content
better better than we do and that's just
hilarious to me it really was actually
humanizing maybe maybe he did it just
for fun but maybe it's the same reason
that northrop grumman puts
advertisements on hulu just so that we
all just get accustomed to thinking
northrop government is a good thing
because i'm not buying f-16s i don't
know someone someone super chatted if i
had elon's money gundams would be real
and functional yeah do you know the
gundam a gundam a gundam is that like a
gun kingdom it's a gigantic robot
like from an ad is an anime
the pilots are in gigantic mechanized
you know oh yeah yeah like voltron kind
of yeah exactly yeah and uh yes i
tweeted at elon musk why haven't you
built an iron man suit yet yeah and he
responded building starship and then i
said that's an acceptable response
that is acceptable okay that's cool my
because my point was basically like why
aren't you going crazy like you have
you're you're an eccentric dude
why aren't you just being like because
it's time work dude work work is life yo
and if you're that guy or if you're me
or if you're somebody else who's working
nine to five work is life get up work
hard be tired that is i get it i get it
i get it bro if i had a billion dollars
you know what i would do i would hire a
prank monkey like mr burns yeah you ever
see that simpsons episode where he hires
homer as his prank monkey
no
he's like you know homer splash lenny
and then he does then mr burns laughs
and then homer splashes carl and goes
good god man that's carl and then he's
like he helps carl to the chemical watch
you know what i would do i'd hire a
prank monkey what would their job be i'd
be like i want you to just culture jam
buy billboards culture jam buy
commercials
do things that shock people out of their
routine i want someone driving down
sunset boulevard to see like a billboard
that is confusing as confusing can be
just weird
disruptive confusing stuff just kind of
like to shake society by the shoulders
and be like this is nuts you know what i
would do if i had a billion dollars i
would buy every billboard in times
square and say vaccine mandates are
wrong
you know that's interesting uh thing to
get doesn't cost that much money would
they sell them to you
knowing that that's what you were going
to say did he did have one
the negative times times square thing
let me see if i remember i do remember
they had a billboard
i don't know did you see the funding
that they achieved for this 22 million
dollars bro that is a good chunk of
change that is a lot of operatives in
the field
yeah veritas has had a time square
billboard oh snap yeah covet gang
busters with their ratings yep twitter
banned us they can't ban the truth yeah
yeah yeah money talks baby maybe maybe
some of them wouldn't but you could do
so much that's interesting to change the
world for the better
if you had this money and they don't do
it but you sir are doing it bit by bit
they do do it
and they do to all over it
mackenzie bezos putting billions of
dollars into critical race theory right
yeah it's just the problem is even jack
yep that's right he funded that academy
or something jack dorsey funded ibrahim
candy yep to the tune of millions
and millions and millions of dollars and
that means that means jack dorsey is on
the wrong side jack dorsey's evil jack
dorsey is trying to lead america off the
cliff he's trying well i think what you
basically have is
a really dumb guy
who's jack yeah
who's like leading people towards their
destruction thinking he's helping oh you
know
um i don't i don't mean like
i i guess i i guess that's a little bit
too blue dumb guy come on ignorant
ignorant there you go big difference
that's what i'm saying a little a little
too low brown a little too blunt
um i i think in a lot of ways he's a
smart dude you know he's started twitter
and he started a square and they're very
successful square is one of the most
successful um
you know financial processing companies
yeah but um
to be as blind and ignorant in politics
and to fund this evil like come on you
know dumb might be a little blunt but
it's a little emotional too yeah where's
where's peter thiel and elon musk doing
the inverse
elon musk goes on the babylon b okay
elon dude give the babylon b guys like
100 million bucks i think i think peter
does a lot of stuff behind the scenes
sure you know he funds things he pushes
agendas he's got he i think he's more
savvy in this regard uh than than elon
than uh than jack for sure
but you know elon elon musk give the
babylon be a hundred million dollars but
look but look but look
we're we're suffering from the same
problem that a lot of people have which
is like why won't that guy do something
the thing is is that you're already
doing something i'm not diminishing a
billion dollars i'm doing what i can do
everybody needs to do what they can do
they have to do their little part they
have to do their medium part they have
to do their big part and we can't just
sit around and be like well why doesn't
the trillionaire do it
and and that's not you and that's not me
and that's not the people that we know
but i just you know i think it's very
easy for people to take the position of
like well why isn't he doing it when is
the savior gonna come when is the daddy
figure gonna come fix everything for us
you have to as ronald reagan said all
meaningful change positive change in
america starts at the dining room table
i get it and that's where we have to
start i i agree but what i mean is so
we're certainly doing stuff we've got
two foundations we've got the technology
foundation which is the on foundation
which is building tech we've got an
alpha that's in production which will
create a decentralized social media
system it will effectively effectively
give everyone a snap of a finger
subscription website that internal links
with other websites so you'll never be
banned that you you go on patreon you
get banned you go on locals you can get
banned you've got any one of these
platforms you get banned if you own the
space if you own the the domains and own
all that they have to ban you one at a
time the domain host has to remove your
domain the server companies kick you off
the servers you know all those things
have to have your cloud you know uh
storage
if you have all of these decentralized
it's harder to remove you and you can
even own the servers in your own home
that's the one thing we're doing also we
also have the truth and media foundation
which is going to be a fact checking
website and we are going to fact check
all of these deceptive and manipulative
news articles they say oh we're trying
to stop misinformation like we're going
to do that we're actually going to do it
and it's and we're going to track and
we're going to we're going to label
these companies that's something that i
can do and it's not easy to do it's been
very expensive
filing all this stuff that dedicating
all the hours to doing the paperwork to
running two different non-profits
massive and i don't have a billion
dollars no that's what is what i'm
saying
as this company grows and more and more
people become members at timcast.com and
support our work
that
those funds are being allocated towards
expanding the work we do
so like what's what what's the expense
that we have like we we have all these
members we're making money i'm building
a a production facility in west virginia
that's going to do multiple things one
of the reasons why i want to do west
virginia freedom one of the other
reasons i want to do west virginia i
want to bring good jobs to the area i
want to help people in the area i want
to improve the economy and west virginia
is one of the poorest states in the
country so i thought this is an
excellent opportunity because you've got
good land you've got good people you've
got freedom we've got people who share
values and we can empower this in more
ways than just having a news company one
of the ways to empower our ideals is to
make sure there are good jobs and a good
economy for the people who agree with us
on our ideals so for every dollar i put
in to this area that dollar goes to a
contractor who you know who lays
concrete he spends that dollar at the
local burger shop for lunch the burger
shop then gets to hire a contractor to
fix their building all of that stays and
circulates in that economy and i want to
bring that economy out here that's
awesome tim i remember on our very first
time when i was the first guest on the
show back in february 2020 i brought up
my dream
of having a building a village
88 acres with a river with a canal
through it that's all you need you can
put tens of thousands of people there
and uh dude kudos to you for like really
pushing that ball forward we've been
looking at land in west virginia and
southwestern virginia and uh trying to
move things forward my time my timeline
is is a little slower than yours because
of my kids and proximity and all that
there's there's nice work bro there's
there's like 100 acres for you know like
300 grand yeah it's i'm not going to
pretend like for the average person they
can just snap their fingers and do it
but
if if you can get the loan do you know
the mortgage property my issue my issue
isn't like the act of acquiring the land
it's like is it time for me to start
tilling the land right because uh
i've got young kids and we've got kids
in school and i'm tied to the area and i
want to be with them i'm hugely invested
in their lives and being there every
single day it's just not time for me to
move to west virginia and start tilling
the land in every which way in the info
way and
building things and such but but it is
where i want to be and my background's
in real estate development too so like
this is like right in my wheelhouse so
to kind of put a bow on what we were
talking about
my main point is
we do not have
the level of resources anywhere near 99
of even other media companies like you
know uh you you look at some of these
traditional media outlets fox news
they have a skyscraper
they have all this money you know what
are they really doing they just rolled
out a vax mandate for for all of their
employees and people are like but new
york's making them do it oh bs
fox news could say screw off we got more
lawyers than you do come at us and the
city would be like
we're going to go to war with fox fox
doesn't care fox bends the knee so when
i when i when i'm pushing the limit
as hard as possible you know what i
could be doing and what everyone tells
me i should be doing when we have money
come in and profits they're like you got
to put it away you got to hire a money
manager invest for your future tim
invest for your future because you're
not going to work forever and i'm like i
want to invest in things that can have a
long-standing impact for everyone
so
you know when we build this building
this facility i'll say
the improvements we do on it for
actually this building for instance that
we you know we have a loan on it of
course the improvements we've done on it
have made it less likely to be sold yeah
of course you put in a skate park in the
basement well we want to we want to be
exciting we want to inspire young people
yeah we want to make it a fun cool place
to be thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time